hello guys I'm riding right I am Jerry
listen before we get to London has
fallen I wanted to give a shout out to
goosebumps yes a movie Hey goosebumps
the movie is sponsoring this shout out
this is true I just do it even if they
were honestly yeah it's a really
worthwhile film it's it's great theater
experience too they captured the spirit
just the right way I was very happy when
they asked us to do this I was like yeah
I called up Jerry and I was like dude
you're not gonna believe who contacted
us it's one of his top 10 favorites of
his top 10 horror sci-fi films yeah yeah
if I'm just looking at horror sci-fi
yeah goosebumps made my list cuz
goosebumps was awesome growing up though
I remember my buddy had them you know
like it was it was it was a ubiquitous
thing I my biggest memory of it was when
we were in third grade you and I there
was miss Renteria one of the hottest
teachers we ever had and she was reading
that book with the dinosaur t-rex
skeleton on the front I forgot what the
book was what it was why there's the
first choose her own and it was a blast
the best cliffhangers of my life for
listening to mr. entertainer reduce moms
anyway they were thrilling and I mean
like like I was all about it like that
was always the kid in the school library
her they were like could you please read
something else yeah you're always with
these scary books and it was like I had
the show and I had even like the
audiobooks and stuff like goosebumps was
my jamm back in the day yes it was it
was all of our jams
so yeah the goosebumps movie starring
Jack Black it'll be on blu-ray On
January 26 they'll feature altar
openings I think an alternate ending to
blooper reel deleted scenes okay check
it out buy it or you know rent it I
would say buy it because once you give
your rent so you're gonna regret not
buying it so just buy it yeah I mean
it's so much fun man like I would I
would watch that movie yeah so there's a
link of the description box to buy the
goosebumps movie anyway guys let's get
to this London has fallen official
trailer number 2 we have talked about
Olympus has fallen for some reason a lot
in our life
I haven't seen any of these trailers
with you yet really I suppose Todd
Butler whose face is always through the
right side it is nice well let's see how
he has to save the president again guys
this time in London
the British
is that this trailer and this be front
of the trailer make you a permanent poor
choices good have four choices security
level this isn't just a gathering of the
world's most powerful leaders it is the
most protected event on earth welcome to
London is president something's wrong
the British
is not accounted for to our friends in
the West balk our number six on the ten
list what do you want your president
that's not going to happen
there's only number six and every day
from this moment forward do be on your
head
we have to find my wife before he fires
the president we're going to kill him
slowly and broadcast it live yeah
you know that don't take me
it comes to a college tutorial they were
do it London is just the first stop just
imagine every major city
into pea it's not just London's the
world
single tear all right here we go
and make no mistake we will find it
and we will destroy you
Mike we're getting you out
right back
that is some impact whoa
oh my god you always need that line oh
my god they're they're really going
full-bore with with destruction in this
one is like a week ya know it looks like
a Michael Bay movie
well before it was like grounded and it
was like it wasn't the white house now
it's like this is a major terrorist
movie and explosions upon explosions
everywhere there was a terrorist element
the first one but it did have more of a
contained more down-to-earth diehard
sort of value a more real than all this
CGI Fester getting in this tree this
does look a little more like it wants to
be White House down in in the big in the
grandness of the action this Hollis has
like a weird exploitation a vibe because
it's taking such familiar imagery for
right now like this is the news turned
into like an exploitation action movie
yeah yeah which always is jarring to me
I like I'm always it's like taking
something that's a little too close to
home and turning it to entertainment
purposes yeah I'm like I could see this
on the news any day like like ya know
and and that's that kind of jars me like
I guess it's effective and people want
to see that fantasy but I was wondering
to me you need this Scottish guy to save
us though yeah like he's not doing an
American accent he's doing something
trying that one line you should have
brought more men those men like they're
turning these like modern-day things and
they're trying to make an entertaining
action flick out of it but it's also
taking a serious vibe so I'm like well I
want something different out of if it's
gonna take itself seriously yeah it's
going for like a lot of cliche moments
I'm seeing the first movie had that
though and I feel like this trailer just
kind of dials up on both because like in
the first the first movie kind of felt
like two movies it was like here's the
Gerard Butler like oh man this guy is
trapped in this situation and he's doing
a really good job and he's in like a
different plot and the rest of the movie
is kind of this like gritty not like big
effects but like you know kind of
exploitation II action movie it's very
kind of grimy true in that sense it
seems like they've just taken both do
you like what you're seeing this stuff
is always jarring to me
it always makes you a little bit
uncomfortable but yeah it is just a
trailer so I can't say this is what the
movies gonna be like I liked the first
movie ok I really liked the Gerard
Butler story like whenever we were he
was on screen I was like this is awesome
I like this because this is so cool the
rest of the movie didn't quite coalesce
for me and I feel like it's gonna be the
same way it's weird I feel like when it
tries to be I felt like with Olympus has
fallen when it tried to be more as when
it actually fell under more cliches in
there serious moment like and I'm
watching this trailer and it's like this
seems so good guy versus bad guy and
Gerard Butler is kind of in the
background exactly what's very now it
has that exploitation II thing where it
it is like the first one had that they
were it seemed like it was trying to
take itself seriously at times and be
hitting but then it would do these sort
of you know big gritty kind of - Ennis
action moments like there's lots of
carnage and destruction and it feels
kind of dark so like white house down
like at least tries to be fun and
swashbuckling about it and Olivia Swan
has this weird because it's trying to be
more it doesn't necessarily read as
cliche to me but it does read is kind of
strange and awkward I don't know like I
feel like these movies could benefit
from either toning something down or
just acknowledging what kind of movie
they are because they want to be a
better movie than they're giving us well
we're in a day and age where when the
main carrots transformers not saying I
like those movies but when it's
transformers you have CGI characters so
you're gonna see CGI destruction it's
another thing when it's like the main
characters are human beings and they're
being thrown into the cgi world of the
real world with all the destruction and
stuff some of it looks like real
explosions a lot of it like even the
helicopter part didn't look real to me
and well yeah I mean they've added more
effects set pieces but what they've also
done is dialed up the urban chaos
they're taking a bigger element from
from real life that is like a very
pertinent issue and showing a lot of it
it just feels like gratuitous but
Olympus has fallen was you got to root
for this one guy who was like needed a
chance at redemption
he got Maclean's he's John McClane right
but it still looks like even though they
took the die-hard format you're still
why we were like okay I still had a
character
be on board with and go on this
adventure with every trailer scene in
this movie I'm like who the [ __ ] is the
main character in this it seems like I
guess it's about the president and draw
Butler again that's what most of the
trailer is other stuff it feels like a
marketing tool yes it's really playing
on the kinds of things we get passionate
about now and that affect us now yeah so
it's not showing us any one particular
person it's just showing us these
moments that will conjure up familiar
feelings and using those to get us in
like I don't think it's ones like us
falling it's the world has fallen thank
you yeah I mean that's just because it's
it's basically going we're doing this
but now in London instead of I know but
then he's like saying the whole world's
gonna go down now of course yeah but the
title is just to make you like to be
able to reach back and go oh Olympus and
now London other in a different place
like it's just the description of the
movie I'm sure it would be the whole
world cuz it's always the world I mean I
felt like the smartest step for this
would have been if they had a take place
on an airplane dead like the second one
and then the third one kind of like in
the streets of New York yeah and then
the fourth one he becomes super I want
it to wait like you know 20 years yeah
maybe scale it back to pg-13 we're draw
Butler's like damn I need a career back
I need to face off with a fighter jet
now and then I would like a horrible
fifth movie yeah just bored nobody cared
yeah where the screenwriting is fallen
let's get the creativity has fallen is
good like case you guys don't know what
I was doing I was doing the die hard
franchise yeah no dude lethal weapons
with Eddie Murphy and Nick Nolte's I
hold out hope for this cuz I'm like
really like Gerard Butler the first
movie like I would like to see him do
that again like I can root for that guy
again in the fantasy of it all but I
don't know movies like this I've always
a little uncomfortable around it just
makes me feel where where they're
playing with something very relevant and
very real so I'm always like please be
careful with that
like please don't turn this it's not
this but it's like imagine if they did
an action movie around 9/11 yeah I would
be like what if the rest of the world
like what it must the rest of the world
think about this because it does seem a
little disingenuous
rush into a situation and make an action
movie out of it and I like how to some
people that's really cathartic I like
how this movie is about an American who
has to save lunch yeah whoo because he's
American played by a Scottish guy I
wonder how so you white how many degrees
of what does that do to the message like
give us like a new English character who
like to get on board with this white guy
is gonna save some other white people
but he's not American anymore so like
he's playing in America but he's not an
American so like is this jingoistic or
not like it'sit's weird that's thinking
too far I might wait to see what other
people are saying that I trust before I
know what's this movie dude Fuqua
director ii know Spike Lee spike lee
director London has fallen fall in 2016
directed by someone else oh he did this
show banshee two episodes of that
interests he did the short film Pablo's
birthday oh dude he did he was a
director and writer for easy money too
hard to kill interest this kinda has a
small reputation you know what this has
reinstall my faith in this movie oh six
writing credits - oh you know it's gonna
be good with the more writers better a
movie is that's what I say I felt okay
about the first one but the first one
straddle a line where I was like you
know I like Gerard Butler just just for
the fun of watching die hard and I think
he's a really good John McClane type but
I don't know I feel kind of like all of
that is amplified by this I feel like
Morgan Freeman's effect in movies has
really gone down I feel like he's
becoming what Christopher Walken was for
a little bit but for dramas and stuff
yeah well and when he popped up in this
I forgot
Aaron Eckhart was the president in this
so I thought he was the president and
then when I realized that he's like the
Secretary of State or whatever he is in
this movie or the Secretary of Defense
first waiting yeah he's the first first
lady I know but I forgot he was he was
in this and when I realized who he was I
was like for some reason I didn't
believe it as much yeah like I felt like
his demeanor would have to be
and if he was gonna be the Speaker of
the House you know I know but it's like
Morgan Freeman was like oh he's so
awesome and then he started just being
like supporting roles in like oh so many
movies and I remember there's a time
where they did that with walking like
walking so awesome let's just start
casting everybody just stuff you know
just have him show up and do that thing
yeah exactly that's kind of like how I
feel about Morgan Freeman yeah yeah
people want someone to bring weight and
and you know respectable lost you know
he's always cool he's always good yeah
he's always like he can turn it on and
off it's just like this is the first
time in a while where I've been like I
don't know if I believe you here like
and I don't know I can't tell if you're
entirely engaged with this or if this
became a lot bigger and crazier as it
went on because like I'm just kind of
surprised they made this yeah this one's
gonna be like Hong Kong as well yeah
where he has to see the same internet
carpet in China it's gonna be bad luck
man no getting me in trouble
this is gonna be die hard but where it's
not only John McClane getting into these
situations he's always getting in these
situations with the president yeah you
were by far the most unlucky president
I've ever and it's gonna run for like 20
movies and it's gonna be always aaron
eckart and and and and Morgan Freeman is
the speaker the house and they will
somewhere along the line we'll have to
go how do these people keep getting
elected and why is he the president we
haven't seen a single scene that really
shows us why is the busy being kids
you're busy being kidnapped and attacked
and I'm like wait to see a little
something to why he was the first what
is happening to American policy right
now that this guy's always gone in and
he must be doing some injury he must be
doing something [ __ ] up if everyone
what's the joke that yeah anyway guys
listen if you're new to the Chanel
subscribe today by clicking this button
reasons to GRE is a playlist of Jerry on
this channel and dank Estee was a
podcast hosted by Jerry and I think it's
about time I acknowledge why we have a
black background
you can't feature any other brands in
this video people is the only brand
worth featuring is goosebumps the movie
please let's watch it yeah okay wait
let's do that with my thumb life beanie
Roger yeah there's no such thing as
takes oh this is cut that out this is
wrong it was doing a medium-rare cut
that out
get that last part why well I don't know
cause like cause it sounded silly and I
don't know when this is gonna go out you
talking about you or what I said no what
I said no I don't care about what you
said you look like an idiot
that's really mean of you can't swear in
this video ha now you have to cut it out